dans ce cimetière de vive une mère de
drapeaux jaune et bleu au dessus des
cercueils des soldats Ukrainiens tombés
au combat
et pour chacun d'entre eux une famille
éplorée venue leur rendre hommage et se
recueillir en se triste anniversaire du
début de la guerre
j'ai espoir que ça va se terminer cette
année et se terminer par une victoire
dioxana Chabanne une mère ajoutent-elles
ne devrait pas devoir souffrir autant
[Musique]
de l'est à l'ouest du nord au sud une
population unie dans la douleur qui
cherche un sens à cette folie meurtrière
et qui se recueille pour prier à la
mémoire des disparus
des commémorations marquées partout par
la discrétion et la retenue ici par
exemple à quartier la ville est presque
entièrement déserte il faut dire
cependant que les rassemblements sont
interdits ici et par toi à travers le
pays aujourd'hui pour des raisons de
sécurité
[Musique]
une exception à Kiev ou le président
Vladimir Zelinski a rendu un hommage
public au courage des soldats ukrainiens
et à la détermination de la population
avant d'ajouter que son peuple résilient
la rendue invincible alors que l'Ukraine
entre dans une deuxième année de guerre
depuis le début de l'invasion russe le
président zellinski est devenu émotif en
pleine conférence de presse quand il a
rendu hommage à sa femme et à ses
enfants hier le blond je les aime de
tout mon cœur a-t-il dit ce sont les
personnes les plus importantes pour moi
et je ne les vois pas assez souvent
il a aussi évoqué l'espoir que suscite
selon lui les efforts de médiation du
gouvernement chinois il y a quelque
temps qu'on respecte le droit
international et notre intégrité
territoriale a-t-il dit on peut
travailler avec la Chine
une note d'espoir donc en cette journée
anniversaire et un cadeau venu de
Pologne les premiers chars léopard 2
tant attendu par l'armée ukrainienne 1er
d'une longue série un atout important
pour un pays bien déterminé hasser
l'envahisseur et à mettre fin à la
guerre au cours de la prochaine année
ici Jean-François Bélanger Radio-Canada
parking